in britain what time do you all use you
lose y'all's virginities at like in the
uk is it like 10 or 11 or is it 17 like
uh
i say it's 15 to 17. now and indoors are
outdoors people doing it more field oh
wow well i was a uh a latch latch door
what did you call them in america latsky
latch key kid so you had the so
you was if you was home nobody else it
was just you well yeah so i took my
the girl back to mine oh
and then i was like i was i was like i
can't do that i thought i'm scared i
can't do this of course and then as she
was leaving i saw all of my friends
faces pointing and laughing at me like
lino and giuseppe and emma and pete and
tate all going ah
and i was like no i must do this oh
laughing i touched you laughing because
no laughing because i wasn't going to do
it
so i go upstairs and i go into my room
and it's a single bed
and we can't fit on it oh yeah
only room oh no here really my mom's
that's all right you're a bad man
what about you marky how'd you get rid
of it huh uh i remember i was grounded
so there was a time crunch
and this girl was like oh my friend
wants to meet you oh this is bad i was
wearing white jeans it was that
christmas oh yeah and i met her like
behind the wall like we're in muck and
stuff it was raining mm-hmm and she was
just kept giving me green lights oh yeah
to keep going at one point i was on my
knees and mock oh never knew what i was
doing not a clue
i was just like instead of raining and
stuff and
just it happened but i didn't realize
that there was an ending that's
beautiful i just thought you were just
doing it and i was like okay
hold on so so there was no ending for
you no wow damn i just because i didn't
even know what it was
yeah but like mine was over in seconds
might have always i've ended i had sex
early
i am not yeah people doing sex they
start breaking a sweat i'm like
how would you ever break a sweat dude i
can start a tv dinner and i am done with
sex but
i with enough time to [ __ ] be right
by everybody i don't have sex with
people i didn't fancy just to have long
sex oh wow oh now we're talking issues
that was an irish thing too you'd
fantasize you'd have sex with your bed
but you wouldn't fantasize about the
hottest girl is the girl that you would
have sex would have no one found out oh
so how old were you
i was i think maybe
i want to say maybe 15 or something
behind the bowling alley in our town
and you could hear the pins going down
inside you know give me power
i felt like it did anyway you know just
hearing that you know like people in
there just
yes you
know here's a question here's a question
for you people started throwing rocks at
us as well just like in their gaza strip
or like in the middle east
and i was just doing what i could man
so they started throwing rocks at you
because they knew that you were having
sex yeah the friends that were trying to
write yeah they were excited or they
were trying to you know cause mayhem or
something you know or just be a part of
it i think they were jealous it's like i
can't be there with this rockwell and
they would throw a rock over okay so
here's a question
can you remember the third person that
you had sex with
i can't remember the second one
no because i i remember the second but i
don't know her name
oh wow
second or so okay second person you had
sex with
mm-hmm no idea that's weird isn't it
yeah that is weird isn't this yeah
yeah
and then third is just like what could
be anyone yeah i haven't reached the
third person here yeah they could walk
up right now and i'd have no idea yes
please very pleased to
we've met before
oh yeah
have you ever spoke to your first
since
no
but i put an a i've put her name in a
song
of mine and perhaps i shouldn't have
done that
because she'll be a mom
oh yeah you know
you're like you're dirty i think it's
some i think it depends on the woman
some women don't mind if you kind of
idolize moments like that or not idolize
but like uh
put them in the memoriums or whatever
i lost my virginity
she's in the vicinity of
was it deborah that was no no it wasn't
deb man deb was willing though i know
that
deb is always willing is deborah a name
in your country oh yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah i did have sex one of the first
viewers there
bro unbelievable man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one